the next in the series is the hasso
guy shushier the light
is a like a flailing sweeping
movement uh
you're striking across their their face
it ends up in a sweep we do this in the
uh 31 joe carter
and kimi jo of course so so this
uh this suburbie is
designed for you'd have that same
feeling within the carter
okay so the print supports and the
accuracy needs to be the same again
you can do i didn't in the last one but
again you can do the
different steps
so forward together stepping back
so please try the steps in in all the
pesos just to familiarize your own body
with what one you you like
i do the same as the last one that has a
pressure shield
i do this i shift the weight
strike the head
step back and this you'll see my hand
open close it
shift white turn the hand
just strike across their face
once you've hit across their face
just turn the back foot open
on the ball of the foot
pushing stepping back
the back of the rest here
should be facing not this but this
should be here
it's twisted so that in the carter
when you untwist it it brings that
spring feeling through your body
that's spring feeling if you have it
here
you have to manually
do this strike this is
hex hips
hips so this is where why we need to get
this
back of the wrist
back of the wrist at a good angle try
and keep the finger not
here but covered over
now it'll feel very difficult so what
you do is you
look you find it within your body you
perhaps
bend a little lower a little
tip pelvis a little
you will get this
correct by adjusting your body
not by adjusting your wrist by adjusting
softening your body
okay so when you have a problem in any
technique
look further than the hands
what's holding the jar or the arms even
you know the body
does so much there's joints everywhere
that you can knees ankles wrists
there's joints everywhere elbows where
you can
also take up the slack and move
something
to fit a better place this is one of
those
times you need this
the one across the body saying
sadly i have weak knees i've had them
since
in my 30s so if you see them giving up
on me occasionally
twinge uh please forgive me but
that's something i have to put up with
when you get carried away and you start
to enjoy it too much
this happens
people start stepping back before
or at the same time as they strike
if you do this how are you going to hit
their face
you're backing off from them this is
incorrect
you've got to stand your ground hit them
and then
step off so the timing is a is a very
much a pros and cons here you get it
wrong
all it becomes is a carter of like a
dance
with no meaning get it right it's a
martial art
that's how close you get to correct
getting it right
strike step
strike strike
so you strike and it's like a sweep
strike
and then sweep strike
and a sweep strike
and sweep
i said guys you should have bad eye
okay so the three different footwork
forward
middle back shifting the weight
try to build from the earlier ones
to get to the each the next stage
[Music]
g
stepping too soon means you don't get
full power to their head
it becomes a dance
31 cards
don't worry they're going to start
remember don't look down
you don't know where your foot is by now
you're not been training
long enough
don't look down
it leaves us now too